this video contains some major spoilers
for the Hyperion cantos by Dan Simmons
at some point during the hegemony the
bizarre structures known as the time
tombs appeared on the distant world of
Hyperion it was thought that the large
objects had been constructed at some
point in the distant future and had been
sent backward through time just as the
creature known as the Shrike had been
there were six structures in total the
obelisk the Sphinx the strike palace the
cave tombs the Jade tomb and the crystal
monolith the time tombs lay in a valley
below
obelisk glowed softly a stone Sphinx
seemed to absorb the light a complex
structure of twisted pylons through
shadows on to itself other tombs were
silhouettes against the Rising Sun each
of the tombs had a door and each door
was open Kassadin ooh that they had been
open when the first explorers discovered
the tombs and that the structures were
empty more than three centuries of
searching for hidden rooms tombs vaults
and passageways had been fruitless
the time tombs emanated an anti-entropic
field which created temporal distortions
called the time tides the effects varied
between each tomb these time tides
increased over time each tomb also had a
specific purpose but not all of them are
revealed in the series the crystal
monolith for instance was named for its
crystalline structure but practically
nothing is known of its hidden nature
the Sphinx on the other hand was
explained in much greater detail the
Sphinx which resembled the creatures
described in old Earth myth was a
structure full of narrow and uneven
halls which varied widely in width
and led to nowhere in particular it also
contained many strange and unusual
shapes in its design eventually it is
understood that the Sphinx is a portal
through time the Sphinx led forward into
the time when the time tombs were first
created hundreds made attempts to enter
the Sphinx's portal but all failed
except three and it is not known why a
select few are allowed to enter while
the vast majority are not the strike
palace was named as such due to its
similar appearance to the Shrike
creature the structure was domed with
many jagged arches and buttresses giving
it a bladed and thorned look eventually
it is revealed that the strikes tree of
pain was in fact not a physical tree at
all but an advanced simulation within
the shrikes palace lay countless humans
connected by neural interface within the
simulation they experienced
incomprehensible amounts of pain pain
which the Shrike broadcasted into the
void which binds attempting to draw out
the enemy of the AI ultimate
intelligence the human ultimate
intelligence like the crystal monolith
almost nothing is known of the nature or
purpose of the cave tombs just that they
are a group of caves which exist in the
valley of the time tombs the Jade tomb
however stands out due to the green glow
it emits the entrance to the labyrinth
of Hyperion also waited at the base of
the jade tombs Hyperion was one of the
nine labyrinthine worlds which each
contained a mysterious system of
underground tunnels the labyrinths were
created by some long-gone race which the
humans of the hegemony named the
builders the actual purpose of the Jade
tombs may in some way be related to some
exotic Auster's who have been bred to
survive on gaseous planets
the purpose of the obelisk tomb remains
ambiguous though it is vaguely suggested
that it could contain the Shrike army
glimpsed by the character fed monk Assad
at some point in the future this is not
clear however the obelisk could also in
some way be related to the Brotherhood
of mieux a seemingly religious group
interested in shaping mankind's destiny
who vanished from galactic society after
the hegemony fell Dan Simmons leaves
much of the detail concerning the
purpose and the origin of the time tombs
open though it seems to be clear that
they are tied directly into the purpose
of the Shrike
[Music]